schwerstarbeit für drachen lenker
sturmtief diese love hegt seit
mittwochvormittag über die ostsee es ist
der erste größere herbststurm in diesem
jahr in zinnowitz steht der komplette
strandabschnitt unter wasser und auch in
travemünde zeigen sich erste
überschwemmte flächen doch gerade hohe
brandung und starker wellengang treiben
die menschen in die steife brise
wunderbar also da wird an der kopf frei
geblasen endlich mal ein bisschen sind
also deswegen komme ich eigentlich her
wegen der wind wirklich das meer zu
sehen wenn es so aufgewühlt ist und so
also der wind ist schon ganz schön kalt
aber wenn man sich ansieht kann man das
gut aushalten
laut dem bundesamt für seeschifffahrt
und hydrographie werden böen mit bis zu
windstärke 11 erwartet in der lübecker
bucht und dem greifswalder bodden sind
sogar wasserstände bis zu ein meter 40
über dem mittleren wasserstand möglich
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren